who would win in a fight with a
Wolverine and Deadpool even he is smart
enough tonight on the edify with
Wolverine come on
[Music]
I like it the lab bible customized yo-yo
which looks like car wheels I liked it
when I was 10 I competed in my Kimble
public school yo-yo competition and I
won in the final let's see oh yes I got
just checking on the most extreme thing
I've done to prepare for all is
definitely physically like the Wolverine
body doing that takes a long time it
involves obviously training about three
hours a day eating crazy types of food
for many many months but then the last
36 hours and don't do this at home not
drinking any water when you dehydrate I
shouldn't even be telling you guys
that's the crisis that's the most
extreme thing I've ever done rocking the
crepe rocking the cradle okay alright
let's hope you edit as kindly for me I
was the yo-yo champion a pinball public
school this is one I did to win that
competition what I did forty seven
consecutive loop-the-loops
and there I managed to do three I have
known someone who can fart like twos
right the Balrog will be their fine art
my favorite thing about Patrick Stewart
anemic ailment is they've known each
other since they were very very young
and when we were doing Days of Future
past
they both had almost recliner chairs
like lazy boy chairs brought in and so
the two of them would put their legs in
between takes they would chat they would
have their cups of tea because they're
very British and they would often fall
off and have a little nap and someone
would go up very quietly and say sir
Patrick and so he and we're ready
for you on set and they would recline
the seats back up
the leg rest down and then that would
walk arm-in-arm to set it was very very
cute now give me all come on let's make
it interesting
my second talent is something that my
brother and I thought would be our way
to get into the Guinness Book of Records
when we were young and it's catching
coins although by the way don't do this
with a suit on I think the world record
is more like about 85 when he's let's up
the ante yeah
alright that was three coins we're up in
the ante a little bit here I've gone
from three coins to 77 coins
well maybe Nathan
[Music]
yes we're up the cradle
[Music]